yeah welcome to this video playing oh
wow FMS m3m okay we transpose back to a
Sicilian e6 I will take on c6 in most
cases anyway so I six is a bit of a
strange move to be honest hmm ok going
to see some jumped it's all some bit
mysterious but anyway let's play not too
slowly trying to figure out what sense
those whose might have will take a long
time and probably they are not very good
simply just sitting there and trying to
figure out this is very awful just not a
good idea to just get on with your with
your moves that you play anyway ok so in
that case um knight Knight to f5 as a
move that it's not bad at all why the
number of good options even the check on
h5 is not bad
check that it's difficult to say what's
better I have to turn down the volume a
bit it's a bit bit loud so he went
Bishop f7 pretty much instantly well
well i didn't think that this is
particularly good but ok so let's see he
just gave me that really nice queen
position down on g4 which prevents his
some possibility of castling long ok so
here I have Bishop f4 but in my tic and
really play g5 it looks a bit bonkers
but you might still do that so let's go
back to f3 simply trying to take on e5
and how it starts to think at a
situation where blacks position is
already very bad will be diff that's a
difficult position to to find any any
good moves in ok um yeah let's go to age
three men keeping the launch a sling out
of the out of the picture yeah that's
interesting i can take or i can simply
play king age one king h1 i have if i
take it and play 92 that should be quite
ok it gains the tempo on the default
pawn and i have various interesting
ideas to try to continue if I for
example is a pretty interesting idea
just opening the position up even more
yeah its product it's probably right
should be a good move
okay i did that i didn't even consider
because it tooks totally unplayable
Bishop g5 em and then e 69 f 4 I think
you had to take however I mean it is
terrible for black anyway but this is
just completely winning for white that
that's designed to open up the hub it
should be 69 f for rookie 1 and T
explodes on e 7 yeah Bishop g8 is kind
of ridiculous oh no and his seven gets
lost
black resins yet the typical case of
dashing out moves instantly that are so
bad that you can't recover from that um
yeah I have to have six this is just bad
just bad black has no development it's
got a ton of weaknesses and they have
very clear ideas to continue it's just a
bad position the engine gives this roof
which is also not a bad idea try to play
this and pick up that pawn it's pretty
difficult for black to UM to address
that idea I mean if you go like b6 to
preempt that I also have this idea for
f4i note that white is completely
developed I mean you've got everything
out castled everything and black has
moved to spawns and Queen to c7 and it's
got tons of weaknesses now but this is
them this is a direct way to do it and
we r f 4 already gets tries to open up
the position yeah the engine wants to
castle which is probably better however
after takes and takes white will have a
long-term advantage due to the fact that
if I was just a week pawn yeah there are
ideas like let's say we are putting the
bishop over I wanted to know it does at
some delay a bishop over to g3 night
back to f3 I'm just concentrating on
picking up b5 and what a black has
absolutely no play at all so this is
better than the game but still not a
particularly great choice I was thinking
relatively speaking Queen f7 is better
than Bishop f7 but I don't know he
played all that instantly so okay after
that I mean I'm basically gaining a
temple on the pawn and I'm preventing
him from castling so g6 and after this
this yeah that's already already
probably probably no way to get out of
this really engine is on +1 one point
something and it climbs you know no age
five it doesn't help but I don't really
what to recommend to black if he's
playing something like that of course
I'm going if I've you have to open up
while you're ahead and something that
something like this is just instantly
winning Here I am so cannot defend that
okay yes this move but after this blacks
falling apart it's just non-playable
unplayable set up this this green cheeks
and this is soon this is Jack you're
going to be a disaster rookie won
everything is in the attack for just one
pawn engine is on plus what one point
something and climbing is a matter of
giving it some time if you give it some
time it will climb to 22 lots of lots of
a big plus that same yeah h5 went back
check this one out okay it doesn't
really matter anymore this is beyond
repair yeah now I don't know the engine
is not giving e5 surprisingly maybe if
you give it more time I'm pretty sure
it's the right move it wants to play a
three Bishop in before which is not a
bad idea strategically speaking
undermining the pawn chain but I think
this is a pretty good move even though
the engine doesn't doesn't agree okay
after that it's lost ya dead lost and
kind of clear so the only thing is to
take and try to try to somehow weather
this storm and the engine gives this and
only gives right a slide plus this is
surprising I was thinking that this
should be a mere strong enough to
justify wide advantage that's pretty
good defense now and if i move the Queen
now he can cancel on something like this
okay yep agreed so I did really i didn't
really pay attention to this more i was
seeing Queen f5 after which at least
like
can take and have a good position but
like Queenie six is strong yeah Queen if
I was a much much better defense um yeah
f5 is just resigning the whole thing and
he's six and over just just no
resistance yeah and white wins white
wins everything yeah he just played them
I mean it's it's an old it's an old
story and I keep mentioning that he just
played the opening part of the game far
too quickly obviously he had no idea
about the opening the way he played it
so at least take some time and avoid
moves that are quite yeah hopefully to
an FM obviously bad like f 6 a-6 and so
on or this is just not good so I think
if he takes a bit of time he could avoid
that and it was really a case where you
don't come back from that it's just just
too bad okay well thanks for watching